what's the craziest thing you have ever
done in a
car oh no I there's things that I don't
want to say um oh those are the best
ones you just you get up to Mischief as
a kid and you might like throw things
out windows I did that once I littered
once out of a car and it was the one and
only time I've ever done it oh this is
maybe worse than litter it was no you
just no let's just um anyway it's
another red light next
have you ever been naked in a car yeah
me too yeah I may have got a knock on a
window once were you changing or were
you alone were you with somebody uh I
was changing definitely changing wink
wink all righty um be honest you obey
the speed limit definitely more than
[Laughter]
you